wir können nicht mal Sauerstoff geben
wie können wir hier helfen wenn ihr
keine Zeit verlieren wollt probiert es
so schnell wie möglich woanders so sieht
es in einer Klinik in drawdow südlich
von Peking aus doch in den umliegenden
Kliniken ist es nicht besser das
Personal ist am Limit
hier in der Notaufnahme arbeiten wir
nonstop jeden Tag von Schichtbeginn bis
Schicht Ende ohne Pause
überfüllte Intensivstationen überfüllte
Krematorien eine omicronwelle überrollt
China auch auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt in
Shanghai ist es das Thema worüber alle
sprechen
ich mache mir vor allem Sorgen um die
die noch nicht positiv sind wir haben
die erste Welle schon hinter uns wie
viele Menschen sich schon infiziert
haben weiß keiner
250 Millionen sollen es nach internen
Schätzungen in den ersten drei
Dezemberwochen gewesen sein laut
offizieller Statistik viel weniger
jetzt hat die nationale
Gesundheitsbehörde angekündigt die
Zahlen nicht weiter zu veröffentlichen
zuständig ist dafür ab sofort eine
untergeordnete Behörde es ist die
politische herunterstufung der Pandemie
es ist völlig offen wie sich das jetzt
entwickelt letztlich regiert jetzt das
Virus in China nicht mehr die
Kommunistische Partei dabei begann das
Jahr für staatschefchen den Ping und
seine Partei mit einem Triumph als
Gastgeber der Olympischen Winterspiele
während der Rest der Welt damals mit der
omikonwelle kämpfte war Chinas Botschaft
wir haben die Pandemie im Griff mit
Massentests staatlicher Quarantäne und
monatelangen lockdowns
vor drei Wochen änderte die politische
Führung das plötzlich und lockerte die
Regeln über Nacht ohne Vorbereitung für
Apotheken Krankenhäuser das
Gesundheitssystem die Menschen für
Beobachter ist das auch ein
Eingeständnis dass dieser umfassende
Kontrolle Anspruch die KP hat alles im
Griff kann alles lenken dass das in
diesem Jahr eben immer mehr entglitten
ist und ich glaube das sehen wir jetzt
genau vor Augen dass diese KP-Führung
die extrem ehrgeizig extrem Kontroll
fixiert war dass dir im Grunde jetzt
diese Kontrolle entgleitet
unkontrolliert so rauscht die Omikron
Welle jetzt durchs Land und trifft auf
eine wenig immunisierte Bevölkerung den
Preis für diese kopflose Politik könnten
Millionen vor allem ältere Chinesinnen
und Chinesen mit ihrem Leben bezahlen
und bevor wir gleich mit
spd-generalsekretär Kevin Kühnert
sprechen kurz noch eine aktuelle
Einschätzung unserer Korrespondentin mit
der wir vor gut zwei Stunden hier im
MoMA gesprochen haben
[Musik]
die Aussage die war sehr kurz und vage
es hieß zum Beispiel auch die
Bevölkerung solle sich gute persönliche
Hygienegewohnheiten zulegen von den
hohen infektions- oder Todeszahlen waren
nicht die Rede die 180 Grad Wände in der
corona-politik der chinesischen Führung
die ist für viele hier sehr schwer
nachzuvollziehen drei Jahre lang hieß es
ja das Virus sei so gefährlich dass
diese extremen Maßnahmen nötig sein also
Zwangs Quarantäne oder monatelange
lockdowns und jetzt plötzlich heißt es
das sei eine Corona Erkältung die ganze
Zeit kümmert sich um die Leute und jetzt
ist jeder dafür selbst verantwortlich
jetzt begrüßen wir den
spd-generalsekretär Kevin Kühnert für
einen jahresrück und Jahresausblick
sozusagen guten Morgen herzlich
willkommen schönen guten Morgen lassen
Sie uns erst über das Thema Corona
sprechen und das was Virologe Christian
Drosten gesagt hat wir können das an der
Stelle noch mal einblenden ich lese es
vor wir erleben in diesem Winter die
erste endemische Welle mit sarskopf 2
nach meiner Einschätzung ist damit der
Pandemie vorbei ja Bundesjustizminister
Buschmann von der FDP hat das als
Steilvorlage genutzt und gesagt Weg mit
einem noch bestehenden Maßnahmen
Bundesgesundheitsminister ihr
Parteifreund Lauterbach gesagt haben
Moment jetzt bloß nicht unvorsichtig
werden wird es da im nächsten Jahr 2023
in Streit in der Ampel um den richtigen
Weg geben wir haben ja gemeinsam im
Bundestag mit der Ampel Mehrheit mit FDP
grün und SPD beschlossen wie der Pfad
jetzt auf den letzten Metern der
corona-pandemie auszusehen hat das ist
das aktuelle Infektionsschutzgesetz das
gilt noch bis ich glaube zum 7 April das
ist das Datum wo es ausläuft und da sind
ja gegenüber dem was die letzten drei
Jahre hatten nur noch ganz wenige
Maßnahmen drin zum Beispiel im
Fernverkehr die maskenpflicht und das
allermeiste das liegt in den Händen der
Länder das heißt wenn Herr Buschmann
jetzt appelliert zu diesem Gesetz was er
selber mit beschlossen hat dann
appelliert er an die Länder ich würde
sagen wir erleben jetzt noch vier Monate
Abschiedstournee des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes und wenn es
dann keine Mutationen gibt dann wird es
auch wirklich in die Phase der
Eigenverantwortung übergehen müssen wenn
wir uns trotzdem anschauen was ich da in
China gerade abspielt haben sie da auch
Sorge was zum Beispiel die Lieferketten
angeht gerade bei den Medikamenten die
ja bislang zum größten Teil auch aus
China kommen gut wir haben ja jetzt
schon seit einer geraumen Zeitprobleme
mit den Lieferketten was den
chinesischen und teils auch
südostasiatischen Raum angeht wegen
dieser
verkorksten corona-politik die dort
gemacht wurde man muss auch wirklich den
Unterschied noch mal rausarbeiten wir
haben auch harte Einschnitte in
Deutschland gehabt aber immer mit dem
Ziel durch gute Impfstoffe und Stärkung
unserer Immunsysteme dafür zu sorgen
dass wir mit dem Virus umgehen können
china hat nach dem Prinzip Augen und
Ohren zuhalten versucht das Virus
irgendwie sich wegzudenken das hatte man
nicht funktioniert und viele Menschen
werden das jetzt mit ihrer Gesundheit
und ihrem Leben dort bezahlen und dass
wir unabhängiger werden müssen von
chinesischen Lieferketten das gilt
unabhängig von der Frage von Corona das
sind wir unserer eigenen
wirtschaftlichen Unabhängigkeit Schul